one the person has to want to receive
the message to
the person selling the message
the the messenger
messaging may only relate to a certain
audience it may not relate to everybody
it's not easy
this messaging that you're that your
dad's teaching that taught this is not a
popular messaging where it's like
you know jordan talks about in last
dance
he says if it wasn't for his dad he
wouldn't be always if it wasn't for his
brother he wouldn't be who we used today
right there's a scene where his dad's
like
ah whatever michael just go do you
listen man you're not you're not a man
you go out there and just play with your
toys we're gonna go out there and fix
some things
and jordan says when you're going
through it
it's psychological torture when
someone's doing that to you yeah like
your dad is doing that to use challenge
you know
but he obviously responded to it he
became an assassin in the game of
basketball because he received it
correct the individual has to receive it
as well the individual has to receive
that and also but i think the modern
world's changed because there's a lot
more opposite programming to your
parents than there used to be i used to
go to school finish school come home
play chess i was never really allowed to
really watch too much tv i didn't play
nintendo too much i played chess that
was it that's all i really did so
besides the school teacher and a little
bit of school i had i didn't have too
much outside programming from the matrix
itself but nowadays when you're raising
a child it's far more scary because
you're trying to teach them things
that's fine but youtube's trying to
teach them something else and netflix is
trying to teach them something else and
school is going to teach them something
else more than ever before and on top of
that if you're not a wealthy individual
your wife now has to go to work right
because you have two incomes to pay the
bills so she doesn't even your children
are not even at home with the mother or
the woman who adopts with your ideals
because otherwise you wouldn't be
together now they belong to the state
effectively in many different ways the
school raises them then an aftercare
program then you then internet racism so
now you have a very difficult job and
you'll see even if you look at youtube
now children disagreeing with their own
parents about certain issues no matter
what they are some topical issues
politics lgbt whatever the parents will
say no that's not true well i heard in
school it's true that because they spend
more time inside the matrix than they do
with their own parents now and it's very
very difficult now as a parent to get
that that hard time with your kid and
say resist that i want you to be this
way it was easier when i was raised now
that's scary i think that's actually
it's a very very difficult job parents
have now because of that because the
program is exceptionally strong because
it's entertaining right and we've all
developed adhd and we're all glued to
social media and addicted to our phones
and things are coming through the phone
and that's the argument they tried to
use to ban me i argue that i'm a
positive force and there's far more
negative forces than me on the internet
which are trying to infect the children
than i am that's the argument i have i'd
argue that i'm the complete opposite to
it but yeah it's a scary world it's
scary to have a simple question for you
but it's actually very deep
because you don't understand where i'm
going with this how many times have you
seen the movie the matrix
because this is a major theme of yours
yes and pat i don't want to let the cat
out the bag
you just saw it for the first time
yeah okay so how many times have you
seen the matrix
15 20 15. this has a major influence in
your life this concept correct right
it's it it's an easy way for me to
express in a few words how i view the
world
i've adopted something from popular
culture and i've adapted it to try and
quickly explain if i try and sit and
explain that most people are being used
for their resource they're being
projected a reality that isn't true
they're convinced of things that aren't
true they're promised that if they slave
away hard enough at the end at the end
you'll retire at the end it'll be good
which is a lie
and they're just used for their resource
until they die
to get into that and explain it at
length is difficult but if i say you're
inside of the matrix and they've seen
the movie like what do you mean inside
the matrix you're living inside of a
projected reality and your body heat is
being extracted in real time for the
machines that's what's happening to you
like i don't understand you will
understand once you break free
how do i break free you break free when
you can talk freely
this is the thing that's amazing and i
talk a lot about money but i'm not that
financially driven i just understand if
you don't have money you can't have an
opinion you can't say what you think you
can't do what you're not told to do
because then you can't pay the mortgage
if they say wear a mask to come to work
even no matter how much you know that
mask is fruitless you must pay the bills
you must comply that's the matrix you
have no force but to comply it's only
when you get to a point of money where
you can say no my principles are worth
losing x million
that's when you can escape the matrix
money is a primary motivator to escape
i've always been interested in freedom
more than money it's all about having
nice things it's about having freedom of
mind and freedom of thought and freedom
and autonomy over my own body that
requires money
or it requires the complete opposite
like i said earlier it's either no money
living on the street
or a lot of money anywhere in between
you're controlled but if you ain't got
[ __ ] and you're on the beach wear a mask
we're gonna take my house ain't got one
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to watch the entire podcast click over
here and if you want to be connected
with experts influencers such as
kiyosaki tate connolly palmentary myself
and others download the app minect where
you get a chance to connect with these
folks by the minute you get to buy the
minute or have face times with them 15
minutes ask them any questions you may
want to have download the admin act and
start connecting with influencers and
experts today
[Music]